-Hi, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show:
At Home Edition.
My name is Jimmy Fallon, and
thank you so much for watching.
We have a great show
for you tonight.
Guys, I want to wish everyone
a happy "Star Wars" Day.
That's right --
it's a time fans say,
"May the 4th be with you,"
which is great, because now
you know what day it is.
Yep, they call it
"Star Wars" Day because of
the phrase "May the 4th
be with you,"
which, as we know,
was how Baby Yoda said it
before his front teeth grew in.
Meanwhile,
tomorrow is Cinco de Mayo,
though, right now
Americans are thinking,
"Yeah, like we need
an excuse to sit around
drinking tequila all day long."
Check this out.
I heard that doctors and
dentists have now started
removing magazines
from their waiting room.
Patients were like, "Oh, no.
Now how will I find out who was
named Sexiest Man Alive
in 1997?"
"Brad Pitt and Jennifer Aniston
are breaking up?"
Now airlines are removing their
in-flight magazines.
So now you're going to have to
find somewhere else
to see a filled-out
Sudoku puzzle
and stick your wad of gum.
I saw that the new
"Twilight" book
is being released
from Edward's perspective.
Yep. Women are so excited,
they're like,
"Finally, something from
a male perspective."
I read that,
for the first time,
murder hornets have been
spotted in the U.S.
So if a worldwide pandemic
can't keep you inside,
introducing murder hornets.
Yep, these murder hornets
sound pretty scary,
so we wanted to find out more.
Joining us now,
one of the murder hornets.
Thank you for being here.
-Jimmy! What's up, man?
How you doing?
-I'm good.
Thanks for letting me
talk to you here.
I got to say,
you sound pretty friendly
for something that's called
a murder hornet.
-Murder hornet? Really?
Is that what
they're calling us now?
Look, we're just
regular old bees
who happen to make things
fall asleep forever.
-Right, but I heard that you've
just been discovered
in our country and that you've
been decapitating our bees.
-Decapi-what?! No, man.
We're just rough-housing
with your boys.
We practice MMA moves
on each other.
-MMA?
-But sometimes, you know, that
horseplay goes a little south.
But it's all in good fun.
You know, the news isn't always
so black and yellow, you know.
-But they're saying
bee-keeper suits
can't even protect humans
from your stingers, though.
-Bee-keeper suits also don't
protect you from drowning,
but I don't hear you calling
the ocean "murder water."
-I guess that makes sense.
-You know, you jump
in front of a bus
with a bee-keeper suit on,
and they're not going to call it
a "murder bus."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get your point there.
-You just got stung, Jimmy.
-Okay. Look, if you don't want
to be called murder hornets,
what do you want to be called?
-Ooh! I'm just
spit-balling here.
Maybe, um...spicy bees?
-Spicy bees?
-Yeah, grumpy bugs.
Little fellas who woke up on
the wrong side of the bed.
Hornets who do murder sometimes.
Butterflies, but instead
of butterflies,
they're murder hornets.
-Alright, alright.
I'm glad we got to
the bottom of all that.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-My pleasure, Jimmy.
Also, quick shout-out
to my crisis P.R. team,
HWC & Associates.
I owe them everything.
I'd be nowhere without them.
Alright, I got to go do some
"MMA moves" on your honeybees.
Murder hornet out!
-Thank you very much,
grumpy bug.
We have a great show tonight.
Ashton Kutcher and
Mila Kunis are here.
They're going to talk to us
about quarantine wine.
This is their wine
that they have
where all profits go to
four separate charities
for COVID-19 relief.
It's kind of an amazing idea,
and they pulled it off in
perfect amount of time.
I also like that
the label is blank
so you can write
who you're thankful for
or what you're thankful for
while you're having
a little quarantine wine.
Also, we have Evan Rachel Wood
from "Westworld."
Just --
The finale was last night.
She's going to talk a little bit
about that, but no spoilers.
And then we're just going to see
what else she's up to.
I believe she's learning
how to play piano.
She's that amazing.
And we have great music tonight.
Oh, my goodness.
She's one of my
all-time favorites.
Honey --
-I'm freaking out.
-I know.
We've just been playing --
-We have been playing
that album --
-"Diva."
-Over and over again.
Annie Lennox. Oh!
I want Annie Lennox on the show
every single night.
I love everything about her.
I think she's the coolest human.
She came on our show
a couple years ago --
no entourage, just walked in,
Annie Lennox, had a book.
That was her entourage --
a book.
A dog-eared book.
And I go,
"Can I get you anything?"
She's just that cool.
I just love her.
She's going to talk about this
thing called Project Angel Food,
which delivers meals to
people in Los Angeles
who are seriously ill.
It's a beautiful charity.
And she's going to sing a song
for us tonight
with her amazing voice.
I love you, Annie Lennox,
so much.
This is so fun.
Also, I want to say
Mick Jagger is here
on behalf of
savethechildren.org.
Please go to that website
and do whatever you can.
We would love that,
and thank you so much.